pourquoi les avocats rejette-t-il ce
projet de loi ce projet est
véritablement une catastrophe pour les
citoyens qui n'auront plus accès au juge
jean rey conditions normales leur
parcours va être semé d'embûches avec
les amendements que les parlementaires
ont introduit on peut fusionner demain
la cour d'appel de dijon avec celle de
besançon on peut transférer des pans
entiers du contentieux et à dijon à
nancy par exemple pourquoi pas et
inversement
donc on a pas on n'a aucune garantie sur
ce que sûr que demain il a juste aidé
territoire telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui et garantit pas du tout au
contraire
quelles seraient vos priorités pour la
justice on nous explique numérique est
la solution à tous les problèmes
or en fait l'équipement en numérique des
tribunaux est très très insuffisants et
les moyens financiers qui sont consacrés
à justice dans le projet de loi ou
partent vers la construction
d'établissements pénitentiaires
or la justice elle a besoin
effectivement de moyens mais des moyens
humains elle a besoin de magistrats elle
a besoin de greffiers pour qui des
avocats se mobilisent tine entreprise
véritablement pour les justiciables se
dire que la justice telle qu'elle nous
est promise demain c'est plus une
justice de proximité c'est plus une
justice où le justiciable pourra voir
son juge cette justice qui s'éloigne de
façon inexorable